Welcome to our video on top cyber
security interview questions I
have time Landing that coveted interview
or even worse bombing interviews left
and right it might be time to start
prepping for those tough interview
questions preparing for interview
questions is an important part of the
job search process and can greatly
increase your chances of getting the job
you want the cyber security field is
constantly evolving which means that you
need to have a strong understanding of
the latest Technologies and techniques
in the industry this makes cyber
security interviews challenging as
interviewers may ask many complex
questions about various cyber threats
security controls and vulnerabilities by
spending time preparing for these
questions you will have the knowledge
and skills required to tackle them with
ease and before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a show
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page and you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered and if these are the types of
videos you would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press the
Bell icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn so without any further Ado
let's get started with the top most
important cyber security interview
questions so we'll start with the first
question that is what is CRF or you can
say the into us can you explain what
csrf in the context of cyber security
and we can answer that certainly csrf
stands for Crow site request forgery it
is a type victim is authenticated the
attack takes advantage of the trust a
website has in the authenticated users
browser now we'll see how it works so
security vulnerability that occurs when
an attacker tricks a victim into
performing an unwanted action on a
website or web application in which the
attacker creates a malicious website or
injects malicious code into a legitimate
website that the victim visits and when
the victim is it's the attacker's
website or the compromised legitimate
website the malicious code can execute
without the victim's knowledge a
malicious code sends a request to the
targeted website or application on
behalf of the victim this request may
include sensitive actions like changing
the victim's password making Financial
transactions or modifying personal
information since the request originates
from the victim's browser the targeted
website or application considers it
legitimate and processes the request the
victim's account is compromised and the
attacker gains unauthorized access or
performs unwanted actions to protect
against csrf attacks web developers can
Implement several countermeasures
including using ntcis RF tokens using
anti-csrf tokens web applications can
generate and include unique tokens in
each form or request these tokens are
verified by the server before processing
the action and showing that the request
originated from the same website the
next is same side cookies and attribute
web developers can set the same site
attribute on cookies which prevents them
from being sent with close site requests
thus reducing the risk of csrf attacks
verifying the origin header servers can
check the origin header to ensure the
request originate from the same domain
the next is implementing strict Access
Control web applications should enforce
strict access controls and authorization
mechanisms to ensure that only
authorized actions can be performed and
the next measure can be by implementing
these countermeasures organizations can
significantly reduce the risk of csrf
attacks and protect their users
sensitive information and accounts and
the next question is that is the most
important question which interviewer
asks that is difference between xss and
csrf so access that is xss Crow site
scripting and csrf close site request
Hosiery are both common web application
vulnerabilities but they differ in their
nature and the risk they pose so access
is a vulnerability City that occurs when
an attacker injects malicious scripts
into a trusted website which is then
executed by the user's browser this can
happen when the website does not
properly validate or sanitize user input
the injected scripts can be used to
steal sensitive information such as
login credentials or session cookies and
can also be used to modify the content
of the website or redirect users to
malicious websites csrf on the other
hand is a type of attack where an
attacker ticks a user's browser into
making unattended or unauthorized
request to a website this attack relies
on the fact that many website use
cookies or other mechanisms for session
management and these cookies are
automatically sent with every request
made to the website by tricking a user
into visiting a specially crafted
website or clicking on a malicious link
the attacker can perform actions on
behalf of the user without their
knowledge or consent potentially leading
to unauthorized actions data
manipulation or account compromise in
summary exercise is concerned with
injecting and executing malicious
scripts within a website while csrf
involves tricking users into performing
unintended actions on a trusted website
both vulnerabilities can have serious
consequences and it is important for web
developers to understand and mitigate
these risk through proper input
validation output encoding and security
mechanisms such as csrf tokens and
secure session management now moving to
next question is xss client-side attack
or server side attack so xss that is
cross-site scripting attack can occur on
the client side which means it targets
vulnerabilities in the user's web
browser or the client application this
type of attack takes advantage of
security weaknesses in the client-side
code allowing an attacker to inject
malicious scripts into a trusted website
or web application once the script is
executed by the user's browser it can
lead to unauthorized actions data theft
or other malicious activities and it's
important to note that while accessor
attacks primarily Target the client side
they can have significant consequences
on the server side as well the injected
script May interact with the server or
exploit vulnerabilities in the server
side code to perform actions on behalf
of the attacker therefore xss attacks
can have an impact on both the client
and server components of a web
application security and the next
question is what is ioc in cyber
security iuc stands for indicators of
compromise these are pieces of evidence
or artifacts that suggest the presence
of malicious activity or a security
breach within a system or network iucs
are used to identify detect and respond
to potential security incidents there
are several types of iocs that Security
Professionals look for the most common
types include file based iocs these
include malicious files such as malware
executables scripts or documents that
have been identified as part of a Cyber
attack file based iocs can be identified
through file hashes filing names or
specific file content the next is
network based iucs these indicators
relate to network traffic associated
with malicious activities they can
include suspicious IP addresses domain
names URLs or patterns of network
communications that indicate a potential
security threat the next we have is
behavioral ioses these indicators are
based on abnormal behavior exhibited by
users systems or applications for
example a sudden increase in failed
login attempts unusual file access
patterns or unauthorized system
modifications can serve as behavioral
iocs the next is registry or system
configuration iucs these indicators
involve changes or additions to the
Windows registry system configuration
files for other system settings
attackers May alter these configurations
to gain persistence on a compromise
system the next is threat intelligence
iocs these iocs are derived from
external sources such as cyber security
vendors government agencies is or threat
intelligence platforms they provide
information about known malicious actors
their tactics techniques and procedures
and specific indicators associated with
their activities when organizations
collect and analyze iocs they can
proactively detect and respond to
security incidents by monitoring for
these indicators security teams can
identify potential threats investigate
the scope of an attack and take
appropriate measures to mitigate the
risk it's worth noting that iucs are not
static and continuously evolve as
attackers develop new techniques
therefore staying up to date with the
latest threat intelligence and sharing
information within the cyber security
Community is crucial for Effective
defense against cyber threats and now
moving to another question that is fifth
question and it is that can you explain
the difference between antivirus and ADR
in cyber security so antivirus and
endpoint detection and response that is
EDR are both important components in
cyber security but they serve different
purposes we'll see them that is first
antivirus that is also known as
anti-malware software it is designed to
detect prevent and remove known types of
malicious software such as viruses bombs
Trojans and ransomware it relies on
signature based detection where it
compares the code patterns or files or
programs against a database of known
malware signatures when a match is found
the antivirus software takes appropriate
action to quarantine or delete the
infected file on the other hand the EDR
goes beyond traditional antivirus
solutions by providing real-time
monitoring detection and response
capabilities at the endpoint level EDS
Solutions are designed to detect and
respond to sophisticated and advanced
threads that may evade traditional
antivirus software they use a
combination of techniques including
behavioral analysis machine learning and
threat intelligence to identify
malicious activities and potential
threats ADR Solutions continuously
Monitor and point such as workstations
servers and mobile devices for any
suspicious activities or anomalous
Behavior they collect and analyze vast
amounts of endpoint data including
process executions network connections
file changes and system configurations
to identify potential security incidents
if a threat is detected EDR Solutions
provide detailed visibility into the
incident allowing security teams to
investigate contain and respond to the
threat in real time while antivirus
focuses on known threats and relies on
signature based detection EDS Solutions
are more proactive and capable of
identifying previously unseen for zero
day threads they offer enhanced threat
hunting capabilities allowing security
analysts to search for indicators of
compromise that is iocs and identify
potential vulnerabilities or security
gaps in the environment in summary
antivirus is an essential component in
protecting against known malware while
EDR provides Advanced threat detection
real-time monitoring and incident
response capabilities to Define against
sophisticated and emerging threats
combining both antivirus and EDS
Solutions can significantly enhance an
organization's overall cyber security
posture now moving to another question
that is IPS versus firewall that is can
you explain the difference between IBS
and a fireball in cyber security so an
IPS that is intuition prevention system
and a firewall are too distinct but
complementary security mechanisms let's
see the differences between them so
firewall acts as a barrier between an
internal Network and external network
typically the internet it examines
incoming and outgoing Network traffic
based on predefined rules or policies
its primary function is to enforce
access controls and permit or deny
Network traffic based on factors such as
IP addresses ports protocols and
application types firewalls work at the
network layer layer 3 or the transport
layer layer 4 of the network stack on
the other hand an IPS is designed to
detect and prevent network based attacks
it goes beyond the basic Access Control
functions of a firewall an IPS monitors
Network traffic in real time searching
for signs of non-attack patterns for
suspicious Behavior it can detect and
block unauthorized access attempts
malware Network intrusions and other
malicious activities IPS systems are
typically placed in line with network
traffic and can operate at the NATO
clear that is layer 3 transport layer
layer 4 or even the application layer
that is layer 7 to summarize a firewall
acts as a gatekeeper controlling the
flow of traffic into and out of a
network based on predefined rules it
focuses on access control on the other
hand nips is a more advanced security
mechanism that actively inspects Network
traffic identifies potential threats or
attacks and take Section to prevent them
it focuses on detecting and preventing
intrusions in practice organizations
often use both firewalls and IPS systems
together to provide layered security
firewalls protect against unauthorized
access and filter out unwanted traffic
while IPS systems add an additional
layer of protection by actively
monitoring and blocking malicious
activities so this was all for firewall
and IPS now moving to what is security
misconfiguration so security Miss
configuration refers to the improper or
insecure configuration of systems
software applications or network
components that can lead to potential
security vulnerabilities it occurs when
security settings permissions or
configurations are not appropriately
defined or implemented leaving systems
and data exposed to potential attacks or
unauthorized access security
misconfiguration can take various forms
such as using default or weak passwords
leaving unnecessary services or ports
open not applying necessary security
patches or updates misconfiguring access
controls or falling to implement secure
communication protocols these
misconfigurations can provide attackers
with entry points into a system allowing
them to exploit vulnerabilities gain
unauthorized access or carry out
malicious activities organizations often
face security misconfigurations due to
human error lack of awareness or
inadequate security practices it's
crucial to regularly review and audit
system configurations employ secure
defaults disable unnecessary features
Polo security best practices and stay
updated with the latest patches and
updates by addressing security
misconfigurations organizations can
significantly reduce their attack
surface and enhance the oral security
posture of their systems and networks so
moving on to next question that is what
is Waf and its types so WF stands for
web application firewall it is a
security measure used to protect web
applications from various types of cyber
attacks a Waf acts as a filter between
the web application and the external
network monitoring and analyzing
incoming and outgoing web traffic there
are primarily two types of wfs commonly
used in cyber security that are network
based WF this type of WF is implemented
at the network parameter typically as a
dedicated Hardware Appliance or a
virtual Appliance it intercepts web
traffic before it reaches the web
application server and network based wfs
examine packets at the network layer
inspecting IP addresses ports and
protocols to detect and prevent
malicious activities they are effective
in protecting multiple web applications
hosted on the same network
infrastructure and the next is host
space WF this type of WF is is installed
directly on the web application server
or within the application itself it
operates at the application layer and
has a deep understanding of the
application structure and logic host
based wf's Monitor and analyze HTTP
https traffic inspecting the content of
requests and responses they are often
integrated as a module or a plugin
within the web server or the application
framework host paste wafs provides
granular control and coin protect
specific applications or modules within
a server both Network waste and host
based wfs add their strength and can
complement each other for enhanced
security network based wfs are suitable
for large-scale protection across
multiple applications and servers while
host based wfs offer more precise
control and visibility into application
specific vulnerabilities and attacks
it's important to note that while wfs
are valuable in safeguarding web
applications they should be used in
conjunction with other security measures
like regular application batching secure
coding practices and vulnerability
assessments to ensure comprehensive
protection against evolving cyber
threats now we'll see another question
that is could you please explain the
difference between Bluetooth and red
teaming so blue teaming and retiming are
two distinct approaches used in cyber
security to enhance the overall security
posture of an organization and blue
teaming primarily focuses on defense and
proactive measures blue teams are
responsible for protecting the
organization's assets system and data
from potential threats and attacks they
typically include cyber Security
Professionals within the organizations
who work to identify vulnerabilities
monitor networks and Implement security
controls blue teams conduct risk
assessments perform security Audits and
develop incident response plans they
also monitor security system analyze
logs and use various tools to detect and
mitigate threats essentially blue teams
act as a Defenders ensuring that the
organization's defenses are strong and
resilient on the other hand red teaming
takes an offensive approach that teams
are independent groups or individuals
who stimulate real world cyber attacks
to evaluate the effectiveness of the
organization's security controls and
practices their goal is to identify
weaknesses gaps and vulnerabilities in
the system red teams use tactics similar
to those of real attackers such as
social engineering penetration testing
and vulnerability assessments to Encore
potential security Force by adopting the
perspective of an attacker teams provide
valuable insights into the
organization's security vulnerabilities
allowing The Blue Team to improve their
defenses in summary blue teaming is
focused on defense while red teaming is
focused on offense blue teams work to
prevent and mitigate cyber threats while
red teams act as adversaries to identify
weaknesses and improve the
organization's security
the collaboration between blue and red
team is crucial in maintaining a strong
security posture and effectively
protecting sensitive information so this
was all that is the difference between
glutamine and vitamin now moving on to
the 10th question that is what is false
positive and false negative in case of
ideas so in the context of intrusion
detection system that is IDs false
positive and false negative are two
important terms used to describe the
accuracy of the system in identifying
and classifying security events a false
positive occurs when an ID is
incorrectly identifies a Banning
activity or event as malicious on the
other hand a false negative happens when
an IDs fails to detect an actual
malicious activity or event it occurs
when an intrusion or attack goes
unnoticed and is not flagged by the
system this can be quite dangerous as it
allows malicious activities to go
undetected potentially causing harm to
the system or network ideally an IDs
should strive to minimize is both false
positives and false negatives however
there is often a trade-off between the
two increasing the sensitive and IDs to
reduce false negatives may result in
more false positives and vice versa
balancing the detection accuracy is
crucial to ensure that genuine threats
are identified while minimizing the
number of false alarms so to improve the
effectiveness of an IDs continuously
monitoring fine tuning of detection
rules and incorporating machine learning
algorithms can be employed additionally
it's important for security teams to
carefully analyze and validate alerts to
distinguish between false positive and
true threads ensuring efficient incident
response and mitigation now moving to
another question that is what is TLD
so TLD stands for top level domain in
the field of cyber security in the
context of the internet a top level
domain refers to the last segment of a
domain name located after the final load
it is also commonly known as domain
extension example of tlds
include.com.org.net.gov.edu and Country
specific tlds like dot UK dot FR or dot
a U tlds play a significant role in
cyber security as they help identify the
purpose or category of a website cyber
Security Professionals often analyze
tlds to assess potential security risk
or determine the legitimacy of a domain
malicious actors May exploit certain
tlds such as those associated with
phishing malware distribution or floor
land activities security measures like
blacklisting or filtering can be
implemented based on tlds to protect
users from accessing potentially harmful
websites overall understanding tlds is
essential in the cyber security field as
it aids in identity find and evaluating
potential threats enhancing website
security and safeguarding users online
experiences so this was all about TLD so
the next question is can you explain
what name servers are in the context of
cyber security so in the realm of cyber
security name servers play a crucial
role in functioning of the internet a
name server also known as a DNS server
domain name system is responsible for
translating human readable domain names
such as www.example.com into IP
addresses such as numerical
representations that computers use to
communicate with each other in simple
terms when a user types a domain name
into a web browser the name server is
responsible for resolving that domain
name to the corresponding IP address of
the server hosting the website this
process is essential for establishing
connections and enabling communication
between devices on the internet from a
cyber security perspective name servers
are vital because they act as
authorative sources for domain names
solution however they can also be
targeted by malicious actors in various
attacks such as DNA spoofing or DNS
hijacking which aims to manipulate the
translation process so to mitigate this
risk organizations employ various
security measures such as implementing
TN ssec domain name system security
extensions will secure ensure the
integrity and authenticity of DNS data
DNS firewalls and intuition detection
systems can also be utilized to detect
and prevent malicious activities
targeting name servers overall name
servers serve as critical infrastructure
component for the internet and
safeguarding their integrity is
essential in maintaining a secure online
environment so the next question is what
is canonical name in the context of
cyber security so canonical name refers
to a standardized and both creative
named assigned to a network resource
such as a domain host or IP address it
is used to establish a consistent and
unambiguous naming mentioned across
different systems and networks the
canonical name serves as a unique
identifier for the resource ensuring
that it can be accurately located and
accessed within a network or across the
internet the canonical name is commonly
represented as a fully qualified domain
name fqdn for a website which includes
the domain name and OLED subdomains for
example
www.example.com is the canonical name
for the website example.com by using the
canonical name organizations can
maintain a centralized and reliable
reference point for accessing resources
making it easier to manage and secure
the network infrastructure in cyber
security the concept of canonical name
is particularly relevant when dealing
with activities such as network
monitoring access control and threat
detection it allows security
administrators to establish policies and
rules based on the canonical names of
resources ensuring consistent
enforcement and effective security
measures by leveraging canonical names
organizations can Advance the cyber
security posture by effectively managing
and protecting their network resources
facilitating accurate identification and
control of assets and enabling efficient
incident response and mitigation
strategies so this was all about
canonical name in cyber security Now
moving on to another popular question
that is what details you find when you
search IP or domain for DNS lookup so
when performing a DNS lookup for an IP
domain in the field of cyber security
there are several key details that can
be obtained these details provide
valuable information for assessing the
cyber security posture and potential
risk associated with the IP or domain in
question here are some important details
that can be found that is IP or domain
ownership so the DNS lookup reveals the
registered owner of the IP address or
domain name this information helps
identify the entity responsible for the
IP or domain and can be useful in
determining its legitimacy the next next
is IPO domain reputation the DNS lookup
May provide information about the
reputation of the IPO domain this
reputation score indicates whether the
IPO domain has been involved in
malicious activities in the past High
reputation scores indicate a secure or
lower risk level while low scores may
suggest a higher risk of involvement in
cyber threats the next we have is IP or
domain geolocation the geolocation
information obtained from the DNS lookup
reveals the physical location associated
with the ipodomy this can be useful in
identifying potential jurisdictional
issues and determining the origin of
suspicious activities the next we have
is IPO domain history the DNS lookup can
incur historical data related to the IPO
domain this includes information such as
previous ownership changes in IP
addresses or change in domain
registration details examining the
history can help identify any patterns
or suspicious behavior for previous
environment in cyber incidents the next
is DNS records the DNS lookup provides
information about the DNS reports
associated with the IPO domain this
includes details such as the IP
addresses associated with the domain
mail server information subdomains and
other records like txt records used for
various purposes such as SPF standard
policy framework or DM Arc domain-based
message authentication reporting and
conformance configurations the next is
IPO domain blacklisting a DNS lookup can
reveal whether the IPO domain is listed
on any known Blacklist blacklisting
occurs when an IPO domain is identified
as being associated with malicious
activities spamming or other undesirable
Behavior such listening can indicate a
higher risk level so by analyzing these
details obtained from a DNS lookup cyber
Security Professionals can access the
potential security risk associated with
an IP or domain and take appropriate
measures to protect systems and networks
and now moving to next question that is
what is DHCP that is can you explain
what DHCP is and its role in cyber
security so DHCP stands for dynamic host
configuration protocol it is a network
protocol commonly used in computer
networks to automatically assign IP
addresses and network configuration
settings to devices within a network
DHCP plays a crucial role in cyber
security as it helps in managing and
securing network resources effectively
one of the primary functions of thcp is
to introduce or provide IP addresses
dynamically to devices when they join
the network by assigning IP addresses
dynamically DHCP prevents the need for
manual configuration making it easier to
manage a large number of devices in a
network this automated process helps
ensure that devices are correctly
connected and can communicate with other
devices and Network Services in the
context of cyber security DHCP helps in
enhancing Networks security by enabling
features such as IP addresses management
and network access control here's how
that is IP address management DHCP
allows Network administrators to
centrally manage IP addresses by
controlling IP address assignments
administrators can prevent unauthorized
devices from connecting to the network
this help in mitigating the risk of
unauthorized access and potential
security breaches the second is network
access control DHCP can be used to
enforce network access control policies
for example an organization can
configure DHCP to assign different IP
addresses that ranges or provide
specific network settings based on user
roles or device types this allows for
granular control over network access
ensuring that only authorized devices
can connect to specific Network segments
or Services additionally DHCP servers
can be configured to provide additional
information to Connected devices such as
DNS server addresses default gateway
settings and other configuration options
by centrally managing these settings
DHCP reduces the likelihood of
misconfigurations that could introduce
security vulnerabilities moving to next
question that is what is CV which
authority generate CV annual answer cve
stands for common vulnerabilities and
exposures it is a system used in the
field of cyber security to identify and
track known vulnerabilities in software
and Hardware the purpose of CV is to
provide a standardized way of
referencing And discussing security
vulnerabilities across different
organizations vendors and researchers
The Authority responsible for generating
CVS is the mitr corporation that is
Mitre is a non-profit organization that
operates the cve program under contract
with the national cyber security
ffrdc that is federally funded research
and development center they maintain the
official CV list assign unique
identifiers to an vulnerabilities and
facilitate the sharing of vulnerability
information among cyber Security
Professionals and organizations by
signing a CV identifier to a
specifically vulnerability Mitre enables
cyber security researchers vendors and
organizations to refer to
vulnerabilities consistently allowing
for effective communication and
collaboration in addressing and
mitigating the identified security
issues so this was the explanation so we
can also think of providing an example
of a CV identifier so let's take an
example of CV 2021 34567 in this case CV
2021 represents the year the
vulnerability was assigned or discovered
and 34567 is a unique numerical
identifier by referring to this CV
identifier Security Professionals can
easily search for information related to
the specific vulnerability and access
details such as its description severity
affected so software versions and
recommended remediation steps now moving
to another question that is what is a
loopback address so a loopback address
refers to a specific Network address
that allows the device to send and
receive data to itself it is commonly
represented by the IP address that is
127.0.0.1 in ipv4 or colon colon 1 in
IPv6 the loopback address is often used
for testing and troubleshooting purposes
as it enables a device to simulate
network communication without actually
sending data or a physical Network when
a device communicates with the loopback
addresses the data packets and routed
internally within the device's network
stack by passing the physical network
interface this allows the device to test
its own network services or applications
without relying on external lato
connectivity by sending data to the
loopback address a device can verify the
functionality and integrity of its
networking protocols software or
security configurations
from a cyber security perspective the
loopback address can be valuable during
the development and testing of security
measures such as firewalls intrusion
detection system or antivirus software
it allows Security Professionals to
assess the effectiveness of these
measures by emulating attacks or
monitoring the device's response or
stimulate malicious activities all
within the controlled environment of the
loopback interface Additionally the
loopback address is sometimes used by
software developers to create a local
development environment for by running
services on the loopback address
developers can test and debug their
applications without exposing them to
potential external threats or
interfering with other network resources
in summary the loopback addresses
provide some means for a device to
communicate with itself internally
offering a convenient and secure method
for testing troubleshooting and software
development in the field of cyber
security and moving to next question
that is 18th question here we will
explain the concepts of threats and
processes so in the context of cyber
security threats and processes are
important Concepts that relate to the
execution and management of software and
how they can impact the security of a
system so process can be understood as
an instance of a computer program that
is being executed it represents a set of
resources such as memory files and
System state allocated by the operating
system to execute the program each
process runs independently with its own
memory space and resources and can
perform various tasks processes can
communicate with each other through
their inter-process communication
mechanism provided by the operating
system on the other hand a thread is a
unit of execution within a process a
process can have multiple threads and
each thread represents an independent
flow of control within the process
threats within a process share the same
memory space allowing for efficient
communication and data sharing by
utilizing threats a program can execute
multiple tasks concurrently improving
performance and responsiveness from a
cyber security perspective understanding
threats and processes exclusion
malicious actors can expert
vulnerabilities in processes or threats
to compromise security system for
example a vulnerability in a process
might allow an attacker to execute
arbitrary code gain unauthorized access
to sensitive data on manipulate system
resources similarly if a thread is
compromised it could be used to execute
malicious code bypass security
mechanisms or launch attacks on other
threats or processes to enhance cyber
security it is important to secure
processes and threats by implementing
various protective measures this
includes regularly updating software to
patch known vulnerabilities employing
secure coding practices to prevent
common programming errors implementing
excess controls and permissions to limit
process Privileges and utilizing robust
monitoring and intuition detection
system to detect and respond to
potential threats in summary processes
and threats are fundamental Concept in
cyber security as they determine how
software is executed and how resources
are allocated understanding their
implications and securing them
effectively is essential in maintaining
a secure Computing environment so moving
to next question that is 19th question
and it is what is cadburos so Kerberos
is a widely used Network Authentication
Protocol that plays a crucial role in
ensuring secure Communication in
computer network it was developed by
mesochets Institute of Technology that
is MIT and has become a fundamental
mental component of many security
infrastructures as its core Kerberos
provides a framework for Mutual
authentication between a client and a
server allowing them to establish trust
and securely communicate over an
untrusted Network it relies on a
centralized authentication server known
as the key distribution center which act
as a trusted third party when a client
requests access to a Network's resource
the Kerberos protocol enables the client
to authenticate itself to the KDC using
its credentials typically a username and
password the KDC then verifies the
client's identity and issues a Time
limited ticket also known as ticket
granting ticket which serves as proof of
authentication once the client processes
a valid TGT it can present it to the
desired server to request a service
ticket for a specific resource the
server in turn contacts the KDC to
verify the tgt's authenticity and grants
the client access to the requested
resource if the validation succeeds one
of the significant advantage of Kerberos
is that it uses symmetrically
cryptography which ensures
confidentiality and integrity of the
communication between the client and the
server the KDC shares a secret key with
each client and this key is used to
encrypt the communication tickets making
it difficult for adversaries to forge
and tamper with them moreover Kerberos
incorporates the concept of single
signal allowing users to authenticate
months and obtain multiple tickets for
different services without needing to
re-enter their credentials this enhances
usability and reduces the burden of
remembering and managing numerous
passwords overall Kerberos is a robust
Authentication Protocol that addresses
many security challenges in network
environments its widespread adoption in
various systems and its proven track
record make it a valuable asset in
safeguarding sensitive information and
preventing unauthorized access now
moving to the next question that is can
you explain the significance of 0 18 and
012 incurable so authentication so
incredible authentication the value 0x18
and 0x12 represents specific message
types within the Kerberos protocol the
Kerberos protocol is a widely used
Authentication Protocol designed to
provide secure authentication for
Network Services in Kerberos each
message exchanged between the client and
the key distribution center as a special
message for a specific message type
associated with it these message types
are represented by hexadecimal values so
0x18 corresponds to the message type krb
underscore as underscore req which
stands for Kerberos authentication
Service request this message is sent by
the client to request a ticket granting
ticket from the KDC the TGT is then used
to request service tickets for specific
Services 0x12 represents the message
type that is krbt GSR EQ which stands
for Kerberos ticket granting service
request this message is sent by the
client of the KDC to request a service
ticket for a particular service the
client includes strategy obtained from
the kib underscore as underscore req
message and specifies the desired
service these message types are
essential in the kerberus authentication
process as they allow the client and the
KDC to exchange the necessary
information for authentication and
authorization the Kerberos protocol uses
the message types to ensure secure
communication and prevent unauthorized
access to Network Services overall the
values 0x18 and 0x12 in Kerberos
authentication represent specific
message types within the Kerberos
protocol enabling the secure exchange of
authentication and authorization
information between the client and the
KDC and the next question we have is
Define unicasting multicasting and
broadcasting so unicast multicast and
broadcast are the three methods by which
will transmit data over a network so
unicast it sends the information from a
single user to a single receiver we use
this for point-to-point communications
and multicast here data is sent from one
or more sources to multiple destinations
then we have brought first that is known
as one tool that is the communication is
between a single user and several
receivers and the next question is
explain SSL encryption secure sockets
layered SSL is the standard followed in
the security knowledge industry to
develop encrypted connections between
the browser as well as the web server
this standard ensures that data privacy
is maintained and that online
transactions are protected from external
attacks the following steps have to be
followed to established an SSL
connection the browser will connect to
the web server which is secured by SSL
the browser will send a copy of the SSL
certificate the browser verifies if the
SSL certificate is trustworthy if
trustworthy the browser will send a
message to the server requesting to
establish an encrypted connection the
web server acknowledges and starts to
build an SSL encrypted connection the
encrypted SSL communication begins
between the browser and the web server
and now we have the 23rd question that
is what steps will you take to secure a
server so the secure socket layer SSL is
a protocol where data encrypting and
decrypting will protect it from being
intercepted by authorized users the
simple ways to secure the server are as
follows ensure that the password for
root and administrative users is secured
new users can be included in the system
now they will manage the system as per
the policies established remote access
is removed from default administrator
accounts the following steps have to be
followed to configure firewall routes
for remote access now we have the 24th
question that is what is data protection
in transit versus data protection at
rest so when data is protected in
transit the data goes only from the
server to the client the effectiveness
of data protection repeat the
effectiveness of data protection is
critical for ensuring that there is no
loss of data data protection at test it
is when the database is on the hard
drive the data at rest is sometimes less
vulnerable than the data in transit so
this was all about it and the next
question is what is the difference
between VPN and VLAN so VPN the group
workstations are within the same
locations and in the same road cost the
main logically segregated networks and
have no physical connection whereas VLAN
this is related to remote access to the
company Network the connection of two
points within a secured and encrypted
tunnel there is no encryption technique
in bold and it slices The Logical
Network into different sections to
manage and secure different aspects and
this was all for this tutorial or the
interview questions hope you guys found
it informative and helpful let's take a
minute to hear from our Learners who
have experienced massive success in
their careers hi I'm Philip I'm 61 years
old and last year I upskilled with
simple learns postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors with many
companies before the security analysts
and the architect on a contract basis
but I needed some stability which I got
with the job I just started with Infosys
as a cyber security consultant happened
on the first and if you like this
session then like share and subscribe if
you have any questions then you can drop
them in the comment section below thanks
for watching stay tuned for more from
Simply loan staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign